all right alicia's in decatur indiana hi
alicia how are you
hi dave hi christy hi um
thanks for taking my call um my husband
and i are having
kind of a dilemma on what to do with an
inherited ira
um a little back story is we've been
date-ish for
quite a while and at the beginning of
november we decided that we were going
to go full in and you know pay off all
of our debt so we had some more freedom
well since then we paid off twenty eight
thousand dollars worth of debt
good and the only thing um
well the only thing we have left is my
student loan debt
good so it's um right around 40 41 000.
and how much was the inherited ira
88 thousand is what it is yes pay off
your student loan out of that you're
gonna have to
you're gonna have to cash out the
inherited ira over the period of the
next few years
anyway that's the law and you're going
to pay taxes on it as it comes out
no penalties and you might as well pay
your taxes now and be debt-free
yeah it's just a security blanket for me
i guess it's not a security blanket you
have a student loan debt
yeah that's true you have a security
blanket with an
axe hanging over your head that's
true it probably makes sense so it's not
very secure
you know no no no and you know be
debt-free
listen here's the thing when you got all
geared up and you paid off 28 000 since
november
the reason you did that was you came to
believe
that the shortest distance between where
you are and wealth and financial
stability
is to get your butt out of debt right
true nothing's changed yeah
just stay the course take the hit
because not because it's not a hit it's
not a hit it's an advancement
when you see it as a hit you feel like
you're losing money you're taking that
money and you're applying it to the debt
this is a move
forward so we gotta we're gonna reframe
that in your mind when you see that as a
hit
it feels like it feels hard to do let me
give you let me give you an example on
this you took the hit when you took out
the student loan
when you pay it off you admit it
yeah when you buy a car that's 30 000
when you buy a car that's 30
000 and it goes down to 20 000 and you
sell it people say oh i took the hit no
you you already got the hit you already
lost ten thousand dollars
when you sell the car you just admit it
yeah that's all it is it doesn't change
it doesn't change the reality
it just makes you face the emotions of
this student loan was a stupid butt idea
well it's okay we've all done stupid
butt stuff
i made a living doing it kiddo
all right you're gonna be all right
you're doing good i'm proud of you you
know the interesting term she used
security blanket made me think of that
call in the last hour where they they
had 7 500
had a debt of 10 000 but didn't want to
pay it off because it was that same
concept of like
this makes me feel safe because i have
this money here it's an illusion it's an
illusion and it's like the idea that
that is keeping you safe and it's
somehow going to be a move backwards to
pay off the debt
no no that is the move forward and you
know what that
that does bring up a thing too this idea
that the enemy of the best
is not the worst yeah the enemy the best
is
okay kind of in the middle if you can
just sit in the ugly middle and be
comfortable
you got no reason to bust into
excellence you've got no reason to bust
into the x and it's familiar
it makes me think of in financial peace
university which i when i took this
years ago
you talk about the credit cards oh no
not this last one i'm so attached to
it and there's an emotional attachment
we have these ideas in our head that
even if they're not accurate
mathematically at all about what it's
going to do for us financially
we get attached oh i've got to hang on
to the savings even though i have all
this debt and i'm paying all this
interest
because it makes me feel safe that's not
that's not a reality
me going broke i had an advantage
i didn't have a choice yeah yeah you
were forced i'm sitting there
in the poop and i got to go i got to get
up out of this
because it wasn't comfortable right but
if you're sitting there and you kind of
feel comfortable it gives you this
that that's where the enemy of the best
is not the worst
i was at the worst yeah and i knew it
and i didn't want to be there anymore i
was motivated to get my butt out of
there right
you know but when you're everything's
just kind of okay you know i got my
little ten thousand dollars and
i got my little eighty-eight thousand
dollars and i'm okay
and that your your brain just whines
like that mine does it too on other
things
yeah it's like you know i'm not fat
enough that i'm gonna die
so i don't do anything about my fat you
know you know what i mean but
but if the doc came in and went you're
morbidly obese you're about to die
of a heart attack fat man then i would
go do something about it sure but my
brain is like
my level of fat i'm kind of in the
middle you know until until i hit covet
and then i just got big as a dadgum
house and i had to go so i've lost 37
pounds y'all shut up all right but
uh because i needed to because i was
gonna turn in the michelin man
but um but the you know but you know
it's the same thing isn't it
any area of our life if it's if you can
hit that
that mediocre middle that's a danger
zone you're comfortable
it's a danger zone and it gives you the
illusion that you're doing better than
you are
because you've got this security blanket
whatever your security blanket is it's
like i'm okay
i'm doing okay you don't have that
motivation that you're talking about
like things are bad
i have to change something what did you
oh your quote i love so much you can
wander into debt you cannot wander out
yeah
you got to get fired up if you're going
to do something you've got to get your
team
on anything if you're going to transform
your life it's going to involve the most
painful of all emotions and that's
embracing change stepping face long
into change intentionally i'm going to
step
up i'm going to bust into this thing and
i don't care if it's you know your
marriage is just kind of instead of
having an awesome marriage
you know you gotta you gotta go
something's gotta give
i gotta change something you know it's
like man i tell you the kids
man you know you kids are out of control
when you go that's it
that's it you know my mama used to say
the worm has turned
i don't even know what that meant except
the beatings were about to begin
you know but the uh uh it turned out
shakespeare who knew mom
knew shakespeare but um but you know all
that was was she had reached the end of
her rope you know
yeah the little grand babies the little
girls denises and rachel's little girls
are over at the house of the night and
they're jumping bed to bed to bed to bed
and i'm trying to get them in bed and
sharon's got the boys in other room
putting them down i'm sitting in the
rocking chair and i'm just girls sit
down
girls lay down girls stop it and they're
just getting more and more wound up
and one of them says papa dave's getting
frustrated
yeah it's coming mama mama agreed
she said when mama gets frustrated it
ain't good
so that means my daughter's doing a good
job i like that that's right
so i said girls you're gonna have to lay
down
but i mean the worm has turned you have
to have this moment in your life where
you say
enough i've had it and sometimes being
in the comfortable middle doesn't
doesn't make you do that that's true and
you have to manufacture that in your
emotions and just decide